yeah it was funny I was we were watching
that France game and um
France England and there's the mbappe
guy right and uh yeah who you [ __ ]
love and the guy who was marking him up
was this guy named Kyle Walker right and
he's the fastest guy on the England team
I think he's like the fastest guy in the
Champions League yeah like he's just an
incredible speed and there's a moment
where mbappe gets the ball and it's
one-on-one him against Kyle Walker now
that's the fastest guy in the Champions
League there's the fastest guy not I
mean just sheer speed
can't beat them and the reason they
marked them up is because mbappe is so
fast and Bobby he takes one look at him
and he's just like it's a full race
and he [ __ ] blows by this guy the
balls the confidence that you know they
put the fastest Sprinter on you and with
the ball it's not like you guys are
running straight in a schoolyard yeah
it's move and then go and I don't know
for me I don't know anything about I
don't know anything about soccer I just
relate everything to like basketball the
things I know and it's just like there's
there's a there's a feeling that greats
have when they have a defender in front
of them it doesn't matter if you're the
best defender of the world you are food
and he gave them the you are food yeah
and then he ate yeah it was so he's nice
I mean it was it was cool to see because
the guy that was we were watching the
game with kept gassing his Kyle Walker
and he was going for France he was like
this guy Kyle Walker's [ __ ] good and
I was waiting for that one moment that
they would have the one-on-one and it
was just different level while
controlling the ball yeah that's crazy
but you're not a France fan though
you're a Morocco fan I'm Moroccan I'm
Morocco too Mark France but if anybody's
gonna bet betonline.ag Mark what's your
advice for the rest of this France takes
the whole thing I've said it's from the
very beginning most the most dominant
side ever I think they're the first team
to ever win a World Cup and go to the
semi-final and when they win the World
Cup again they'll be the first team that
win two World Cups in a row so they're
not going to win a World Cup yeah
because Morocco is going to beat them
and Morocco's winning the World Cup
who's your favorite Moroccan player BB
who
no Habibi you can call them all Habibi
and it works okay but it's actually
let's go hubby me and then it works 100
but you're right no Hakimi is nice I
[ __ ] you yo you saw the video I sent to
the chat where hakimi's wife was upset
that he didn't come right to her oh yeah
we don't we don't know if that's true
that's just what somebody said but
there's this video it's great if you
could bring it up and it looks like his
wife actually doesn't look like it
someone just said this but his wife is
going
pointing at him and then pointing about
like this and somebody add the caption
hakimi's wife saying why'd you have to
say thank you to all those other people
before you said thank you
that's funny and then every married man
in that moment was just like yeah he
going through it right now yeah I think
that was because there was one of the
other players like went and kissed his
mom after he's gone oh that same that
was probably what she was like oh that
was probably
look at it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
if
I mean it looks like she's giving it to
him bro hey no way it looks like it a
little hey no John if this is true I
understand why Tom Brady got divorced
I'm not you don't understand what the
[ __ ] I'm doing on any level clearly oh
we're out to you betting yo
yeah I'm putting my money down
betonline.ag you know they're mashing
that uh deposit initial deposit uh 50 of
it up to a thousand dollars okay you put
in a thousand you get 500 500 free to
gamble with you know we going on Morocco
now how much you put on Morocco I didn't
say I was better Morocco
is it your people right listen I'm Pro
Habibi are you on team a BB not all day
so put your money up I mean yeah
I Am pro Morocco that's what I want to
happen I don't who who would I put on to
win the whole thing I don't know I think
Morocco is going to do it I'm doing it
the hockey way that's that's what I'm
I'm betting on the hockey way 100 100 so
bet on
a game
I'm not about to tell these
[ __ ] lose their goddamn money
Argentina Croatia who are you gonna bet
on for that say again Argentina Croatia
I'm going Argentina okay 100 Argentina
get that 50 all right got this [ __ ]
um Croatia looks good
not bad right they look good yo crazy
in France for the majority of the match
we're not talking about what you talking
about yeah yeah you're talking about
talking about that girl about underdogs
in general no no no we're talking about
something completely different come on
right Croatia
yes Croatia we've got the best talent
out there
no no no
[Music]
they need a model budget say hey we're
spending this much money to take the
team out and then we're also spending 10
mil to bring models because all our
models are at [ __ ] our bathrooms
stands at Guitar getting their clits cut
they're all in Bali getting their dick
sucked bro yo they gotta get out of the
box
go to Qatar get your click cut
[Music]
what what happened some Kardashians bro
like we would have won it yeah better
bro the fact that these girls are normal
in there that's crazy that yo these are
their sports fans nah that's some work
that's alone no I didn't say natural
normal
bro that's a big difference yo but shout
out Croatia man Croatia real talky talky
you saw the Arab announcer that started
singing to the hot girl legend yeah
Legend with the foot pick you know I saw
that one they busted in clothes for that
butt pick did you understand it say what
you understood 100 what was he saying
yala Habibi
he was hitting up with that he had you
know he asked he has it
oh come on they suspended the account
bro
[Music]
Elon that's a hate crime